uk health security agency has announced
they have identified eight further cases
of this new variant that's in addition
to the previous five confirmed cases
yesterday it means the total number of
confirmed cases in england of omicron is
now 13. you may
have been with us earlier when the first
minister of scotland announced that
there have been nine confirmed cases
identified in scotland now
five cases in the lannister area and
four in the greater glasgow and clyde
area
what we know about these new cases in
england is that the individuals that
have tested positive and their contacts
are isolating
work is underway to identify any links
to travel to southern africa the uk
health security agency saying that they
have identified cases in the east
midlands east of england london and the
north west they're now carrying out
targeted testing at locations where the
positive cases were likely to be
infectious so that is
13 confirmed cases of omicron in england
that coming from the uk health security
agency this afternoon